sie alle wollen auf und davon die
bündner sabrina und markus blume tochter
amira suchen das einfache leben in der
kanadischen wildnis
vom zürcher oberland nach kambodscha
monika lehnert und peter kruse erfüllen
sich den traum vom eigenen kleinen
guesthouse
carolin schneider und daniel schafer aus
dem kanton bern ziehen mit ihren städten
hunden nach schweden wo sie eine
campinganlage führen
[Musik]
um sie noch
am 1
cool
sie ist ein wunderbares land die schweiz
und doch wollen einige menschen weg von
hier für immer der polizist daniel
schafer ist einer von ihnen noch genießt
er das schwarzenegger land in bern wird
zusammen mit seinen hunden tsunami und
manno zwei von insgesamt 19
schlittenhunden und die sich der 33
jährige kümmert
zudem natürlich extrem schlanker also
für die sie bestimmt was der
fluggesellschaft kommunen zerschlägt der
helfer sind die frachtvolumina thuringia
schrank kommen das ist
aber dass
die hunde sind ein entscheidender grund
dafür dass daniel schafer nach schweden
auswandern will
für sie würde er alles tun es gibt nur
etwas das ihm wichtiger ist als seine
runde
seine freundin carolin schneider
seit der teenagerzeit sind die beiden
ein paar die 36 jährige arbeitet in
basel als pr fachfrau für eine bank
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
für ihren beruf nimmt die tochter eines
schweizers und einer philippinen jeden
tag einen vierstündigen arbeitsweg in
kauf
wegen der hohen beruflichen belastung
und da ihr freund als polizist
unregelmäßig arbeitet sehen sich die
beiden häufig nur noch beim zähneputzen
in schweden wollen sie wieder mehr zeit
für sich
[Musik]
wer sich aus der schweiz auf und davon
macht lässt nicht nur ein zauberhaftes
land zurück sondern auch geliebte
erinnerung auf diese alp oberhalb von
davos haben sabrina und markus blum 1
die hochzeitsfest begangen nun feiern
sie abschied zusammen mit tochter amira
werden sie nach kanada auswandern in
einer abgeschiedenen hütte 12
autostunden entfernt vom nächsten
supermarkt
die blumes möchten der einst pferde
trekking touren anbieten die
werbebroschüre ist bereits gedruckt
diese hütten entdeckte die familie blum
während ihrer letzten kanada ferien
damals schlossen sie freundschaft mit
dem besitzer der jagd häuser
besonders groß wird die gegenseitige
sehnsucht dies arbeiten werden der
zweieinhalbjährigen amira und ihrer
großmutter christa sie christ der mutter
von sabrina während einem tag pro woche
war die enkelin jeweils beim große nun
werden sie sich bald nicht mehr sehen
können
[Musik]
ja
kurz nach vier uhr morgens im
zürcherischen weisslingen sbb
zugbegleiter peter kruse steht einer
seiner letzten arbeitstage bevor
die sonne wird für den 49 jähriger dann
in kambodscha aufgehen
doch bis dahin geht er im elften jahr
seiner beschäftigung als zugbegleiter
nach
heute ist peter criss sie für den ic
nach basel eingeteilt er mag es wenn es
schnell geht im schnellzug tampa hatte
auch seine auswanderung geplant während
einer asien-reise mit seiner partnerin
monika besuchte er die kambodschanische
station gerade vier tage später
entschieden sie sich für immer dort
leben zu wollen und ein kleines
gästehaus zu führen
bei einer pause erzählt peter krause
seinen kollegen von seinem zukünftigen
leben als hotelier
du hast nicht in der regel skizzieren
am 1
das ist ganz problemlos outen sich als
bergwerk bei den natürlichen china
herrscht da muss einfach da das muss
einfach stimmig wie was muss stehen
entweder stimmt das oder der hersteller
fällt zwischen damals aber da jetzt
wieder freuen die neue fähigen zweifel
kaufen
das
ist das risiko durch
[Musik]
daniel schafer ist nicht alleiniger
halter von 19 schlittenhunden knapp die
hälfte gehört rolf einem seiner besten
freunde auch rolf wird nach schweden
auswandern
würden der hunde wohnt daniel schafer
abgeschieden im weiler ross graden bei
hinter folkigen zusammen mit seiner
freundin carolin schneider die ihren
langen arbeitsweg für heute hinter sich
gebracht hat
feierabend bedeutet für sie dass dies
zügig gegen eine arbeitshose tauschen
denn draußen warten die hunde und ihr
freund
die tiere sind auch caroline schneiders
große leidenschaft vor zehn jahren
kauften sie und daniel gemeinsam den
ersten schritten hat damals dachten sie
nie daran der einst ein kleines rudel
dieser hunde zu besitzen
die kurzen
am abend lagebesprechung in sachen
auswanderung rolf kaiser guter freund
von daniel und besitzer der restlichen
100 oz graben bereitet das abendessen zu
der ausgebildete koch wird mit seiner
familie ebenfalls nach schweden
auswandern mit seiner frau silvia und
seiner tochter lena gemeinsam träumen
sie davon eine kleine anlage mit
ferienhäuschen und restaurant zu führen
irgendwo im norden schwedens
bald werden sie dorthin reisen auf der
suche nach einem neuen zuhause nur
daniel schafer muss vorerst hier bleiben
wegen der hunde
[Musik]
ein paar tage später im schwedischen
teil von lappland
eines wird carolin schneider und ihren
freunden schnell klar platz für mensch
und tier gibt es hier genügend
sie liebt die organismus braucht
[Gelächter]
nur wo genau in dieser weiten landschaft
liegt die neue heimat für die
schlittenhunde und ihre besitzer
[Musik]
der 37 jährige markus blum und seine
sechs jahre jüngere frau sabrina wissen
worauf sie sich einlassen bei ihrer
auswanderung ins kanadische hinterland
letztes jahr waren sie zwei monate lang
in der wildnis unterwegs hoch zu ross
die kleine amira auf dem rücken sie
begegneten keiner menschenseele
übernachteten im zelt und ernährten sich
von fisch und schnee hühnern diese
freiheit wollen sie wieder erleben
obwohl sie sich bewusst sind dass ihre
zweieinhalbjährige tochter in der
abgeschiedenheit keine spielkameraden
finden wird
wenn amira in das kindergartenalter
kommt werden sich ihre eltern gründlich
überlegen ob es nicht besser wäre wieder
in die zivilisation zurückzukehren
doch bis dahin ist noch zeit
[Musik]
ein alter wo die bestehenden einfachere
lösung setze natürlich lasse mir nichts
bekannt
am beispiel der kamera
aber ich glaube das ist das ist im
moment
einfach die chance in new york 29 ist
der führerschein zum bauen kann man hat
alles seine
demokraten ergänzen husmann sind gerade
bauen oder den wald oder ist doch
schneider natur müssen die stiege und
wanderfahrer siemens lachen seine
weinende auge das klar oder
das einfache leben ohne wasser und strom
dass man auch so machen sie das ist
einfach nicht alles selbstverständlich
ist
manche menschen sagen das wahre glück
liege im einfachen leben die familie
blum macht sich auf dieses glück zu
finden
frohgemut und ohne sorgen
[Musik]
mit diesem zug kommt zweifellos peter
cruces große liebe
seit fünf jahren ist er mit der mode
beraterin monika lehnert zusammen
kennengelernt haben sie sich über einen
zeitungsartikel in dem peter zum single
des tages erkoren wurde
peter kruse hat zwei erwachsene kinder
aus erster ehe die 43 jährige monique
all ihren hut ist kinderlos
nur zu zweit haben die beiden aber nie
gewann sie teilen ihr heim mit nicht
alltäglichen haustieren
diese wirklich so ans herz gewachsen
wille aber entsetzt musste sie sehen und
somit irgendwie für innerhofer und der
stippvisite nach
galway was macht oder bis
60 minuten nach
schon
zwei werte pendeln
und weiße haus kurz platz
eine schlange und 2 kaiser skorpione
haben sie schon weg gegeben nun kommt
der tierhändler und holt die echsen und
die vogelspinne
sie haben
[Musik]
ja
ja ich gehöre mit die andere können
da
[Musik]
die einen auswanderer geben ihre tiere
beck die anderen wandern nicht zuletzt
wegen ihrer tiere aus
daniel schaaf erhält in der schweiz die
stellung während seine partnerin
caroline und die freunde rolle von
silvia in lappland eine campinganlage
suchen daniel ist fest entschlossen in
den hohen norden schwedens auszuwandern
obwohl er selbst noch gar nie da war
ja so viele schlittenhund erhalten will
braucht erfahrung hingabe und geld
jährlich einen fünfstelligen betrag
[Musik]
berlin
in schweden treffen caroline rolle von
zebra beim ersten objekt ein die
campinganlage rennen wollen steht zum
verkauf
bisher haben sie die riesige anlage erst
im internet gesehen mit fast einer
million franken ist sie viel zu teuer
ausgeschrieben aber vielleicht lässt
sich der preis ja verhandeln
die eigentliche besichtigung ist erst
morgen aber die auswanderer dürfen sich
schon einmal umsehen
genauer betrachtet trübt sich der erste
positive eindruck jedoch schnell
es ist
[Musik]
buchbachs im soul ottonische und je
nachdem wie der wind lagen mit toto bahn
genauso
kategorische kilometer genommen die
älteste plan zum trost effektiven mit
steht ist auch lösungen im anschluss und
daten wissen wir nicht was wird keine
bestrebungen der technik machen und das
ist
perfekt
[Musik]
in der schweiz wartet daniel gespannt
auf neuigkeiten aus schweden
[Musik]
hallo
und wie hält es
anfangs sehr gut ist wirklich so wie
oskar
roehlers film
bauen bauen bauen bauen
bauen
wollen hedgefonds vorsieht früheste
termin esch
mosley zum start der kosten brauche
[Applaus]
ich das ist ein gerät das mit der
tour hätten world tour
im
griff
schlaf gut gestellte knuddeln
während daniel noch nicht weiß wohin er
genau auswandert macht sich von mir
blumen bereit für den abflug
sie haben viel gepäck denn nur das
nötigste ist in der wildnis vielleicht
doch zu wenig
zum abschied sind neben amiras
großmutter nur die engsten
familienangehörigen
erschienen
[Musik]
sabrina die ausgebildete masseurin und
markus der gelernte hochbauzeichner
brechen nun auf in ein leben voller
abenteuer
hätte ich gar nix
[Musik]
amira scheint zu ahnen dass bald alles
anders sein wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nach zwei langen flügen ist die familie
blum in kanada angekommen nun liegen
noch 12 stunden autofahrt vor ihnen bis
zu ihrem ziel ein paar hütten an
abgelegenen black lag
bald sind sie die einzigen auf der
straße es gibt kaum gute gründe sich
hierher zu verirren vereinzelt fahren
große holztransporter durch die sich zur
sicherheit per funk an mehren
[Musik]
prof
kurz darauf verschläft amira beinahe den
ersten bären
zum schlafen
die blumen sind nun definitiv in kanada
angekommen
und dann das
[Applaus]
eine panne der rechte hinterreifen ist
platt markus macht sich an die arbeit
[Applaus]
doch es gibt ein problem der wagenheber
scheint nicht zu funktionieren
[Applaus]
der wagenheber ist tatsächlich kaputt
über
funk versucht sabrina hilfe zu holen
doch niemand antwortet was nun es kann
stunden dauern bis hier jemand
vorbeikommt
willkommen in der kanadischen wildnis
[Musik]
die reise in ein neues leben beginnt für
monika lehnert und peter kruse in einem
bus der zürcher verkehrsbetriebe
retour bildes werden ab sofort nicht
mehr gelöst
monika und peter nehmen kaum etwas mit
einem block keine bücher keinen
fernseher einen container nach
kambodscha zu verschiffen hätte knapp
5000 franken gekostet zu viel geld für
die beiden
während der fahrt erinnert sich monika
an jenen moment zurück an dem sie zum
ersten mal vom auswandern träumte es war
nach einem jahr als au pair mädchen im
welschland
eigentlich
[Musik]
und jetzt ist es so wie immer
nochmals euro von apple
die heimat
[Musik]
knapp 10.000 kilometer entfernt klompen
die hauptstadt von kambodscha
monika und peter bestreiten das letzte
stück ihrer reise mit dem taxi noch vier
stunden bis sie endlich bei ihrem
gasthaus ankommen
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen
das muss doch stress gestanden ist und
die finde ich spannend
gewusel der stadt und alles ja ja
aufgeregt bin ich auch
große vorteile hat versprochen
foto modis kreierter logo
wertvoller machen wie seinem glück kann
man auch unterbringen und dann sind die
bewegung von selbst dass neue streik
doch druck für sie und land jetzt auch
kann schon mal gemacht und das werde ich
sehen dass ich selber schon was
friedrich nach uns gut also bis jetzt
kommt also herr das taxigeschäft und
auch die 30 punkte auch die fristen
schiene
sie sind diesen möglichen pünktlich
brauchen wird bin überrascht
[Musik]
endlich die goldenen löwen das
wahrzeichen der stadt
den weg zum gasthaus kennen sie zum
glück noch
kleist ist er perfekt
ist es was sie macht auch hat eine
gemacht
hatte wieder vereint
ich kann die musik im museum steht
ach ist das schön worden
so
der name von guesthouse wiesbaden
hätte es zu hause
schon mal gut
nach all der zeit hat aber auch
lieber mag wo ist mein dach
max ist der deutsche vor meter des
gasthauses
mit ihm haben monika und peter vor acht
monaten per handschlag die übernahme des
kleinen hotels besiegelt
[Musik]
kompatibel
auf der campinganlage rein wollen die
zum verkauf steht sind fachleute
eingetroffen die bei der besichtigung
der häuser behilflich sein sollen
das ganze wird eine kurze angelegenheit
der hinzugezogene experte für die
bausubstanz ist nicht eben begeistert
und der deutsch sprechender
immobilienmakler versucht gar nicht erst
diese anlage zu verkaufen
die einladung auf einen kaffee hilft der
besitzerin auch nichts mehr ihre
überteuerte campinganlage wird sie nicht
los
enttäuscht waren die drei auswanderer
weg ohne neues heim für sie und ihre 19
schlittenhunde
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auf dem weg zum black lake steckt die
familie blum immer noch fest der reifen
ist platt und der wagenheber kaputt sagt
markus einen einfall
das kaputte rat ist soweit möglich über
den strassenrand steine unter dem auto
rahmen stützen das auto ab so kann
markus das rad ausbuddeln
darauf muss man erst einmal kommen
bald ist die panne behoben
[Applaus]
nein es gibt immer alles ein schönes
auto
die post und andere sehen aber
[Musik]
erst recht wenn man muss
nun sind die blums nicht mehr weit weg
von ihrem ziel einer ansammlung von
jagdhütten am bett lag
die ersten bekannten die sie treffen
sind vierbeiner mit diesen pferden waren
sie zwei monate lang in der wildnis
unterwegs
die letzten 100 meter privatstraße darf
amira ans steuer
er ist normal
keller ist die tochter von briggs oder
münzen den besitzer dieser holzhäuser
vor jahresfrist lernten sie sich kennen
und schätzen nun werden die blues von
kendrick herzlich begrüßt
die familie blum ist in ihrer neuen
heimat angekommen
die schweizer auswanderer erhalten am
black lake freie kost und logis müssen
aber im gegenzug ordentlich im betrieb
mithelfen
rick lebt davon dass fischer jäger oder
sonstige abenteurer in seiner lodge
ferien machen
doch im moment sind keine gäste hier wie
die meiste zeit des jahres es ist eine
einsame und wilde gegend und genau
deshalb sind die blums hier
[Musik]
die schwedischen auswanderer besichtigen
die nächste campinganlage carolin
schneider gefällt sie auf anhieb
die anlage liegt direkt an einem see und
heißt sancho baden
18 kleine hütten studers wie sie in
schweden heißen sind es insgesamt dazu
ein großes restaurant und der preis ist
attraktiv
rund 300000 franken das
nachbargrundstück könnte man für die
haltung der schlittenhunde dazu kaufen
wie der makler sagt
[Musik]
interessante garden kann der makler
stehen und auch der bauexperte ist
zufrieden nur einer weiß noch nicht so
recht rolf kaiser der als ausgebildeter
koch das restaurant führen soll
[Gelächter]
weg vom rechten
weg
das ist alles
als der markt war die auswanderer in den
keller führt spielt karoline dass sie
ihrem traum ganz nahe ist
in diesem moment stellt sie die weichen
in ihrem leben ein
traum und wir brechen wirklich in der
schweiz ich habe einen sehr guten job
bin in einer sehr guten position
mein partners polizist der auch ganz
toll tollen job bearbeitet auf eine
fachstelle verbrechen wirklich mit allen
und wänden in seiner ganzen reihe und
das muss stimmt das muss
zuletzt werden die hütten von innen
begutachtet langsam schwindet auch bei
rolf die skepsis und der tatendrang
steigt
es hat bei rolf etwas länger gedauert
aber nun sind die emotionen da
sind überall aber so man muss die macher
noch immer nicht der bruder haben danach
aber das hier ja auch immer mit eigener
hand zwei wochen dass die einfach so
einfach kann man nicht wohnen ist nicht
möglich
[Musik]
ein paar tage später zurück in der
schweiz fällt er definitiver entscheid
die campinganlage sand vergraben wird
das neue zuhause für 19 schlitten hunde
und ihre besitzer
[Musik]
am ende dieses strandes 300 meter
zurückversetzt liegt das neue zuhause
von monika lehnert und peter kruse das
gasthaus wiesbaden
diese bissigen kreaturen sind die neuen
haustiere der schweizer auswanderer ein
erbe von deutschen vermieter max
momentan sind die beiden nur gäste in
ihrem eigenen guesthouse denn der
mietvertrag ist noch nicht
unterschrieben
20.000 dollar übernahme gebühr haben sie
mit max ausgehandelt ein stattlicher
betrag für monika und peter die für
ihren traum vom eigenen guesthouse ihre
pensionskasse aufgelöst haben
[Applaus]
unterlaufen haben gegen das flüssige
ja
innerhalb von nur vier tagen haben
monika und peter damals entschieden dass
guesthouse zu übernehmen
länger können sie auch max nicht der
immer noch der aktuelle chef im haus ist
und der irgendwie nervös zu sein scheint
was hat max bloß zu verbergen
[Musik]
und so geht es nächste woche weiter bei
auf und davon schwieriger start in
kambodscha der mietvertrag droht zu
platzen und
weiteres übel wird offenbar
in kanada gewöhnt sich die familie blum
als rudimentäre leben auf 20
quadratmetern
das einfangen der freilebenden pferde
wird schwieriger als gedacht
und bei den auswanderern nach schweden
gibt es einen tränenreichen abschied
die viertägige fahrt mit 19
schlittenhunden wir zur großen
belastungsprobe für alle
[Musik]
die
ausliefen
[Musik]